26 days ago joe biden's secretary of
health and human services xavier becerra
came down with kovid
this was very strange you see because
becerra was fully vaccinated and boosted
with those vaccines that we were told
are totally safe and effective and would
prevent people from catching kovid
but he came down with it 26 days ago
and then he recovered and then do you
know what happened yesterday you know
you know i don't even have to tell you
yesterday the fully vaxxed and boosted
becerra who had just gotten over kovid
came down with kovid again
a couple of months ago democrat
representative maxine waters came down
with covid also pretty weird since
waters also was fully vaccinated and
boosted but you know what's even weirder
you know what happened two days ago
you're not gonna actually
you will you probably
maxine waters came down with kovid
again and then the weirdest part of all
do you know what she said when she
announced her second bout of covet in
two months you know what she said she
said the line that they always say she
said she is quote grateful to be fully
vaccinated and to have received two
booster shots
then she encouraged everyone to get the
vaccination and the boosters that did
not stop her from catching kovid twice
in the same
quarter
it would be funny if it weren't so sad
it's not even all that sad that they
caught covid they both seem like they're
doing just fine what is sad
is that they say these things with a
straight face they say it with a
straight face and they expect us to
believe it they expect us to go along
with it
how
how can they do it
oh yes make sure you get these things
that are super duper effective i know
that i seem to be catching covet every
week now but it's really important that
you go get it how do they do it is it
ignorance
no doubt these people are pretty
ignorant certainly maxine waters is lots
of them are
but i don't think primarily this is
about ignorance
i think it's narcissism i think what
we're seeing here is a battle between
the intellect and the will between
seeing things as they are
and dreaming things that never were
between reality and selfish pride
and at every single turn of that battle
our ruling narcissists are choosing
their delusions
and themselves i'm michael knowles this
the michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from alexandra de
berdeja who says i became a member of
the daily wire and i didn't realize how
much i'd enjoy seeing michael's face
during the second half of the show
that's so kind of you thank you
alexandra it is true my face gets much
more beautiful in the second half when
it's all blurred out on youtube that's
why you've got to join
daily wire use code nulls i think that's
the code we have so many codes now head
on over become a member right now it's
very important it's a very good way to
invest your money in a daily wire
membership
another way you might be looking to
invest right now in gold which is why
you got to check out birch gold right
now text knolls to 98 98 98 fear of out
of control inflation is hammering the
stock market the s p 500 is having its
worst start to the year since world war
ii so not only are your savings worth
less you now have less
of it
now might be a good time for you to
diversify into gold the most stable
asset in the history of the world birch
gold is the company that i trust to help
convert an ira or 401k into an ira in
gold and silver that is right not only
will birchgold help you fortify your
savings with precious metals they will
help you do it in a tax sheltered
account amazon stock is down 37 in the
first half of the year tesla's down 40
cryptos are getting absolutely crushed
right now many fear that the hawkish
moves by the fed could stall the economy
so what's your plan the best time to
take action is yesterday the next best
time is today text knolls to 98 98 98
get your free no obligation info kit on
gold from birch gold they are the
precious metals professionals text
knolls to 98 98 98 secure your savings
now
right now it is 8 34 in the morning
central time here in nashville tennessee
the supreme court is scheduled to
release its opinions
in
26 minutes
the opinion that is expected today is
the opinion in dobbs versus jackson
women's health organization this is the
opinion that could and seems likely will
uphold a pro-life law in mississippi and
could very possibly overrule roe versus
wade and planned parenthood b casey
could overrule the fictional
constitutional right quote unquote to
abortion that was invented by by the
supreme court in 1973 this would be the
most
significant
probably most significant political
event
at least domestic political event of our
lifetimes in half a century and we are
waiting with baited breath the democrats
canceled their january 6th hearings
today which suggests that perhaps they
got some word that this big decision is
going to come out
if the decision comes out i think it is
inevitable that we're going to see
rioting from the radical leftists
they've already tried to assassinate
justice kavanaugh over this they have
been illegally gathering outside of the
justices homes for weeks now the
supreme court justice who wrote the
draft opinion that was leaked sam alito
was put into hiding basically to protect
him and his family so we are waiting
with baited breath on this decision the
supreme court
usually runs on time unlike those
politicians and the elected people the
court usually runs on time so this is
very possible we don't know
we could be disappointed i have
instructed my producers to be refreshing
the page every two seconds uh so that we
can we can react in in real time
the
as we all know
the libs cannot admit that they are
wrong and so they if the opinion does
come out to overrule roe v wade expect
wailing and gnashing of teeth from all
the worst sorts of political activists
in the country and it's because they
can't admit that they were wrong they're
they're obviously wrong about abortion
it's there's just no justification for
killing an innocent little baby
but they're wrong on the constitutional
point too no serious legal or
constitutional scholar
seriously argues that there is a right
to abortion enshrined in the
constitution that the framers of our
constitution
hid between the emanations and the
penumbra as an invisible link some right
to kill your own baby it's not there if
anything there is a prohibition on
killing babies because of the 14th
amendment and equal protection and you
can trace this back to blackstone's
commentaries you could make that
argument there's no way to make the
argument
seriously that
there is a constitutional right to an
abortion
they they are insisting on this because
of this battle between the will and the
intellect the intellect says there's no
right to abortion in the constitution
the will says we want it and we're gonna
get it and we're not gonna let logic or
reason or facts or reality get in the
way this is what joe biden's doing right
now on inflation the republicans came
out even before biden got into office
back when the the congress with the
support of many republicans was voting
to spend all sorts of money on covid
lock down the economy print up a bunch
of money there were republicans who came
out and said it's a bad idea because you
can't just print money endlessly and
give it away to people and expect the
economy to remain strong the inevitable
result of those sorts of actions is
going to be massive inflation and they
were mocked and they were derided
and they were hushed up but these
republicans predicted it they said if
you do what the democrats are proposing
you're going to get a lot of inflation
never mind that you're going to stop
american energy you're going to kill the
american pipelines you're going to stop
new oil and gas leases
you're going to create the conditions
for a major war in europe first one
since world war ii all of that is going
to cause prices to go through the roof
you're going to shut down the entire
economy then you're going to open it up
again that's going to create a tension
on the economy that's going to cause
prices to go up so it wasn't brain
surgery okay it wasn't rocket scientist
the republicans said if you follow these
policies you're going to get inflation
then what happened exactly what they
predicted came true and now what's joe
biden doing he's blaming the republicans
for inflation
there's nobody suggesting there's
unchecked inflation on the way
no serious economist so that was back in
july that was back in july of last year
there's no there's no serious economist
who's predicting inflation but all the
republicans were okay and joe biden said
no no they're wrong they're wrong
they're full of it there's no way the
economists don't believe it then what
does he say yesterday to the afl-cio the
big labor union he says actually forget
about this it's the republicans fault
it's sapping the strength of a lot of
families
i grew up in a household
not far from here claim on in wilmington
where the price of a gallon of gasoline
went up was a conversation at the dinner
table it mattered
it mattered to my working family
it mattered
if the price of food went up
the problem is
republicans in congress are doing
everything they can
to stop my plans to bring down costs on
ordinary families
that's why my plan is not finished
and why the results aren't finished
either
jobs are back but prices are still too
high
covet is down but gas prices are up
that's true that the gas prices are up
because of your policies
the policies that you said would not
cause inflation
and the republicans said they would
cause inflation the conservatives
certainly said it ted cruz was calling
this even lindsey graham who's kind of
squishy even lindsey graham was calling
this you're saying this is going to
cause massive inflation
these sorts of big spending policies
certainly
the the conditions for for the war to
break out in ukraine certainly shutting
down american energy that's that's going
to cause the inflation and then he says
what these republicans don't care about
inflation they're stopping me no it's
your agenda
that it did it buddy and it's just
totally
totally
shameless but he can't admit that he was
wrong
the democrats broadly cannot admit that
they were wrong they cannot have a
moment's reflection they cannot sit down
and say oh oh i guess you guys were
right i guess you predicted it
so it's this is what's driving
conservatives crazy because all the
crazy wild kooky conspiracy theories
that conservatives were suggesting about
kovid 19 about the lockdowns for the
past two years about inflation about
foreign policy about immigration about
everything about me about what would
happen if you change the definition of
marriage and if you mainstream things
like transgenderism it's gonna end up in
the schools they said no no it's crazy
it's crazy that's never to happen and
then it did happen and then they look us
in the face and they say no no don't
believe your lying eyes
we we suggested you know i i'm a little
skeptical of the vaccines i don't think
that it's really going to stop people
from catching covet and spreading over
they said you're crazy you're a
conspiracy theorist and then what
happens they all catch covet like every
three weeks now and then they look us in
the face and they have the gall the the
temerity to say i'm so grateful that i
got my vaccines and my boosters
i'm so glad we shut down american energy
i'm so glad we're spending more money
than we could possibly imagine i'm so
glad i'm so glad and
you better keep on doing it why are you
awful republicans standing in our way
and it's the the feeling of being gaslit
on these issues is so
positively infuriating because there's
no reasoning with it there's no logic
there's no argument all that the libs
are foisting upon us is the sheer
tyranny of their will they're saying
facts be damned reality be damned i want
it and i'm gonna have it darn it now you
know what i want i want to look good and
when i want to look good you know what i
wear mizzen and maine right now go to
mizenandmaine.com use promo code knowles
are you taking your first vacation in
forever and you are not sure what to
wear who's ready to cut out early and
hit the links and some new golf gear
that is why you've got to check out
mizen and main i i love mizen and main
they combine the comfort and flexibility
of your favorite athletic wear with the
fit and style of a custom dress shirt
lightweight breathable moisture wicking
these guys will have you looking great
their dress shirts are machine washable
you can skip those trips and the expense
of the dry cleaner you think of all that
time and all that money you'll save
they got famous for their dress shirts
mizzen and may now also makes incredibly
comfortable flannels no tux shirts
performance polos chinos so much more i
love all of them you know i wear oxford
shirts and polos pretty much exclusively
and being of italian descent sometimes i
perspire miss it in maine looks good the
style's beautiful it looks great and it
will keep you dry keep you feeling good
whether you're working from the golf
course or finally taking advantage of
that unlimited vacation policy we've got
excellent news right now if you go to
missoninmain.com and use promo code
noles you will receive 35 off any
regular price order of 125 or more that
is 35 bucks off when you go to m i z e n
a n d m a i n dot com use promo code
knowles
you see the narcissism of our present
culture
not just in congress not just in the
white house
you see it perhaps most clearly
in the amber herd trial
amber heard
was uh out there
you know she she just lost this
defamation case that johnny depp brought
against her she made all these claims
johnny depp beat her
he was abusive and then she was caught
on tape in many cases and certainly with
the testimony of witnesses having lied
and she lost that case now she's going
out and playing victim again even the
left-wing media
are calling her out on it in some cases
she was speaking to savannah guthrie on
the today show and guthrie just asked
this really basic question hold on
you're telling me that
all the evidence all the testimony
everybody who has some knowledge about
this
it's all just wrong they're all just
lying
even somebody who is
sure i'm deserving
of
all this hate in vitriol
even if you think
that i'm lying you still couldn't look
me in the eye and tell me that you think
on social media there's been a fair
representation you cannot tell me
that you think that this has been fair
i absolutely can tell you that i didn't
even watch that much of the trial but
everything i saw suggests this was in
fact much more fair than many trials and
trials in court and trials in in the
press that we've seen in recent years a
lot of evidence was presented and
all of the evidence suggested that amber
heard was lying savannah guthrie pushes
her on this point she says wait hold on
you see you're saying that everything
that came out against you was just bs
but then there are other times there's
another tape where you're taunting him
and saying oh tell the world johnny depp
i a man the victim of domestic violence
20 second clips or the transcripts of
them
are not representative of
even the two hours or the three hours
that those clips are excerpt from could
your side have just put the whole three
hours in then
i'm not a lawyer as i testified to i was
talking in those recordings as a person
an extreme amount of emotional
psychological and physical distress he
says doesn't never
hit you
he never is that a lie yes it is
what about the witnesses who said they
have seen you
instigate physical violence i've seen
firsthand how people will file rank
and support the person they depend on
did they all come in and lie in court
i am not here to call
any of
these witnesses
any names i'm here to just kind of talk
about it from
what it felt like for me as the person
who
sat there there it is
there is the giveaway right there at the
end because she's just denied denied
deny the whole time that old italian
phrase in new york deny till you die
she's just keeping it up and then so
guthrie brings in this
this question of objective reality she's
saying okay well
if if what you say is true amber
then
everyone who testified against you is
either extremely mistaken or more likely
lying
but amber her doesn't want to go that
far because it's absurd and so she says
no i'm not i'm not saying they're lying
i'm just telling you what it felt like
for me
see now it's no longer what it was what
it did what it what the reality is now
it's just this is what it felt like for
me me me me me me it's all about me and
my feelings she is so
insistent
upon her own will on her own desires and
what she wants
that she is
totally ignoring
truth and reality
she's just neglecting she doesn't really
care what it is and when and when forced
to confront that she says forget about
the truth for a second just talk about
me and my
feelings
i want to talk about confused young
women there was a viral clip from one of
the pride parades around the country of
some poor young women who were dressed
up in all sorts of weird
lgbt the baby blue and the baby pink
purple and all the rainbow and the trans
and the this and that and
an interviewer just came out and asked
them on the street hey what does this
mean for you who
why are you here today who are you
i'm gay
what age did you know that you were gay
um
i think at like 10 i knew that i
i think at 10 but i wasn't like
i wasn't clear on my gender
yeah i i think it was around like
10 as well when i started questioning if
i was bi and then since then it was kind
of like a a slippery slope because i
kept i was like my bi omni lesbian and
then i i kind of like
came to the point and the now recently
i've been like in my pan but then i like
i think
now i'm starting to realize that i'm
queer but yeah it was it started around
10. it wasn't like fully
formed but i guess like that's when i
realized wait
that's possibility
yeah i am genderqueer trans mask and
queer what's trans mask trans mask is
like people under the non-binary
umbrella at identifying like or
presenting mask
masculine yeah what about you um
i'm trans and uh
on my sexuality is unlabeled um
i use he him pronouns yeah and i used to
have pronouns he him he they trans mask
i was gay then i realized i'm more pam
trans i don't know you know a little bit
non
bi
transpan
what a wada bing bong
this video was put put up by savannah
hernandez and then her account got nuked
for apparently no reason but you can
still find it somewhere on the internet
apparently you know you can find it on
this show too we were lucky to get it
there it tells you so much about the
culture
and
do i feel bad for these young women i do
i genuinely feel bad for these young
women
do i do i think that the culture and the
society is leading people to these sorts
of disordered and destructive sexual
ideologies for sure of course there's
huge encouragement everywhere you can't
find a corporate logo this month that
doesn't have a bunch of rainbow colors
urging people of every age all the way
down to two years old and three years
old to pretend to be the opposite sex
and screw up their bodies in their lives
so yeah there's a big part of that but
there's a
this goes to the individual as well
it's an individual problem and it's not
just with that confused girl or the
confused girl next to her and it's not
just with the lgbt and the rainbows and
it's really a a totally pervasive
problem for all of us and the problem is
narcissism
do you think there is one second of the
day that those two young women aren't
thinking about themselves
the way that they talk well i was just i
was really focused on myself and in the
trans mask and then i realized no i'm a
little bit more of a pan today and then
i woke up and no i wasn't feeling like a
pan man i was feeling like a pot and a
plate you know i was a little bit more
of a trans by this that
you know there's a whole world out there
darling look at it you look up you can
see the birds in the sky you can see the
fish in the water you can you can read a
book that's great you can read a what
about a great novel how about you open
up jane austen that'll be really
interesting or go watch a documentary or
just i don't know observe other people
and stop thinking about yourself because
if you think about yourself all the time
you're going to drive yourself insane
which is what has happened
to to try to cure
narcissism egotism the the
self-absorption
to try to cure that you don't need to
think less of yourself
the whole point of pride month so they
say is that you shouldn't feel bad about
yourself you should feel really good
about yourself you shouldn't think of
yourself in a low way you should think
of yourself in this really high exalted
way but the the solution here is not to
think less of yourself the solution is
think of yourself less
just think of other things beyond you
think
a little bit less of your desires and
your appetites and your wants and start
thinking about objective reality and
maybe dare i suggest think about your
duties and your obligations and your
roles in your family and in your
community and in your country
think about that it will cure a lot of
those problems
i went back i was i was
going through some christopher lash last
night as a result of this christopher
lash great writer who famously wrote the
culture of narcissism
and he predicted this many years ago
and
what he saw happening in the culture
seems to have been proven truer and
truer every day he saw that since the
late
since the the early 1940s really
you had this therapeutic culture that
was developing and psychologists were
meeting with patients who did not have
really well-defined systems they just
had a kind of
cornucopia of
ill-defined
dissatisfactions they just weren't they
just weren't feeling you know they're
just ah you're just feeling kind of blah
and what am i and what am i doing
he he saw a protective shallowness in
emotional relations he saw people
becoming hypochondriacal
oh my gosh look around the culture we're
a completely hypochondriac culture
everyone seems to think that they've got
some super special little disorder
they use the language of medicine just
to describe perfectly ordinary
personality quirks people say oh i'm so
ocd they don't actually have obsessive
compulsive disorders it's just i'm just
ocd or obviously you see it on the
sexual ideologies i'm trans i'm pants on
this i'm just so special i've got these
medical problems that you can't really
identify anywhere on my body but they're
there they're really and you need to all
cater to me and to my wishes and to my
desires all the time and we always what
lash saw was this special affinity for
therapy just not going to therapy to fix
your problem but just to just to talk
all the time about all you and just
we're always in this therapeutic kind of
culture this fear of aging this fear of
death this fear of time this fear of
commitment this fear of doing anything
outside of yourself but a man wrapped up
in himself makes a very small package
indeed and i know there is this impulse
among so many people to
just coddle
the people who are who are in the thrall
of these ideologies and say oh no it's
okay you're so confused sexually i feel
so bad for you sometimes people need a
little bit of tough love here
it's the narcissism isn't helping
anybody it's so pervasive it's so easy
to fall into for all of us i don't
exclude myself or anyone in the audience
from that but you've got to push back
against it
or we cannot have a society anymore
we need to answer simple questions like
what is a woman i'll tell you about a
great woman gina carano who's the star
of the new daily wire movie terror on
the prairie i loved it saw the premiere
went to the premiere had a great time
there are lots of cool people there the
movie is terrific head on over to
dailywire.com gina to become a member
and watch the movie that's
dailywire.comgina
also
you know we've got the voice mailbag
coming up on
friday so you can still submit your text
mailbag questions you can still go in
there and write them in i'd love to hear
your beautiful mellifluous dulcet tone
so please head on over to my page on the
daily wire
click submit a mailbag question you can
only do that if you're a member
record your mailbag just on your phone
on any kind of app
attach it to the to the email try to
keep it under 60 seconds
people like to wax poetic but you know
we need to fit it on the show
submit it and then hopefully i'll hear
your lovely voice on friday we'll be
right back with a lot more
you want to talk about narcissism in our
culture there is a tick tock video just
went viral from a woman named remy bader
and remy bader showed up to a ranch and
i guess she wanted to ride horses
but there was a problem
so she's walking around the ranch and
she's got a little caption there on her
tic toc video it says shout out to deep
hollow ranch and montauk
for making me leave
because i weigh
over 240 pounds
she's 240 there she is i don't think
they made her leave the grounds i don't
think they said you know you're gonna
fall through the earth and destroy the
crops because you're 240 pounds they
just wouldn't let her ride a horse and
she was really angry about that and she
took to tiktok to complain about that
because it's all about her
you see the whole world is about her
and
the suffering of other creatures doesn't
matter as long as her pleasure is
satisfied
why do you think this woman was turned
away from riding the horses at the ranch
do you think it's because the the
ranchers just hated her do you think
it's because of her terrible oppression
or do you think it's because she was
going to break the back of the horse and
they and they took into consideration
the feelings of the horse as well and
they took into consideration propriety
and what's good and just outside of this
woman's own will
but she says i don't care if we break
the back of the horse what do i care
about the damn horse this is the same
thing that the marquis de sade said
truly the marquis decided from whom we
get the word sadism
his big question was
why is
your pain any more important than my
pleasure
that's
narcissism
that's the extreme
pathological version
of self-absorption and selfishness but
it's it's different it's much more than
just a regular old selfishness which
everybody's got it's this inability to
and unwillingness and
lack of desire to
take into account anyone or anything
else other than
oneself
this will all she she can't even see how
ridiculous she looks posting that to
twitter
not just ridiculous because she's she's
bragging about her weight or says part
of the pop body positivity pride
movement
that that in itself is sort of a
ridiculous thing
but to come out and say can you believe
this they kicked me what about the poor
horse
oh you never thought about the horse
because you you guys
in this culture don't think about
anything other than yourself and it's
very
very sad for everybody involved
we are living in a really
low moment in our culture there's this
prejudice that modern people have that
we know so much more than all those
old-timey people you walk around the
ruins of ancient greece you think are
these idiots they didn't they didn't
even have iphones
you know what a bunch of dummies
aristotle and plato what did they know
they didn't even have computers
what
what a bunch of dumb idiots they had to
walk around places but i have a honda
those dummies they're they were so
unsophisticated
and
so we have this idea that our culture is
really so much more advanced we're not
i think if you really look into
ancient rome at its height
you look into
athenian imperial athenian democracy
athenian imperial democracy really you
look at the great civilizations you
realize they really had it a lot more
together in many ways than we do in some
cases technologically as well you look
at the roman aqueducts for goodness
sakes
and i think the clearest example of this
today
is that while
the ancient athenians may not have had
iphones
they knew
what a woman is
they knew
quite a lot about man and his role in
the universe
probably a lot more than the average
person in our culture knows today
we talk about this question what is a
woman this is a big daily wire
documentary
it's even gotten worse since then i
thought
that it could not possibly get dumber
than having to explain to large swaths
of our population that a man is not a
woman but actually it's gotten even
crazier we now have to explain to people
that elephants
are not people
this was a real court case
we're all waiting on the dobbs decision
from and other court decisions from from
the scotus today
i've got i've got an even crazier court
decision that just came out of the new
york state court of appeals
fortunately it was decided the right way
it was a 5-2 decision so actually
two judges on the court didn't seem to
understand that the case was about this
question are elephants people
this case was brought by the non-human
rights project this is a radical animal
rights group
uh the the organization requested a writ
of habeas corpus to take happy
a female asian elephant that was brought
to the bronx zoo in 1977 away from the
zoo and the the reason they wanted this
this rid of habeas corpus this idea that
you have a right to your body
the group contended that happy the
elephant was not in fact an elephant but
a person
because they argued elephants possess
complex cognitive and emotional
capabilities and therefore because the
elephant was practically speaking a
person it was illegal to confine the
element elephant to the zoo
i'm not denying that elephants
relative to other animals possess
high intelligence
sure
relative to human beings not even close
and a lot of people are confused about
this these days but relative to other
animals yeah elephants seem very
intelligent they possess an intellect
that is appropriate to their animal
condition
but they're not
people
this is a big
distinction here
we used to understand that
human beings are special
human beings uniquely possess will and
intellect
we have language such that we can
communicate not merely our appetites and
our desires but we can communicate in an
abstract and rational way about
objective reality to one another that's
how we're speaking right now that's how
you're hearing what i'm saying that's
how i'm gonna hear from you in the
voicemail bag on friday that's how we
have self-government it's how we decide
what to have for dinner and everything
else in between
that is different from any other animal
including the elephants who are
relatively very intelligent that's true
but the elephants aren't people here's
how i'll prove it to you
if elephants are persons if they are
people
then when they kill
other elephants
when they certainly when they kill
people
we would put them on trial
right that's what happens when you're a
person when you do bad things when
you're a person when you commit crimes
you are held to account for those crimes
and you're given a trial and you have
the right to due process and then you
can be
you can make a defense for yourself or
you get a lawyer and then you're found
guilty or innocent do you think we would
we should have a trial if an elephant
kills some other animal and eats it
no that would be ridiculous
do you think we should even have a trial
if an elephant kills a human being there
are throughout history actually some
really bizarro cases of people of either
as a kind of public spectacle or because
of a great deal of confusion have tried
to try animals and then
hang them or execute them
the reason that these are notable
throughout history is because they're so
absurd we all know every single person
with two brain cells to rub together on
earth knows that it would be
preposterous to put an elephant on trial
why because we know that the elephant
isn't a person
human rights
such as they are
are inseparable from human
responsibilities
human duties human obligations and all
of those things the human rights and the
obligations and the duties are
inseparable from humanity which is
different in kind from the rest of the
natural environment not just different
in degree
like the libs want us to believe
but different in kind we're actually
special we're actually made in the image
of god
and this isn't just some mystical pie in
the sky kind of notion this has real
practical consequences and real
practical effects that we can observe
the fact that we can reason in an
abstract way the fact that we have a
lower will the appetite and a higher
will and we can actually sort of tame
the appetite to some degree
through the rational will that mediates
between the divine will and the appetite
all these sorts of things i'm just
giving you the very
basic overview of the most elemental
aspects of philosophy that have been
discarded because we've replaced all of
that with with will we've replaced all
of that with just i want i want i want i
think the reason that the libs are
confusing animals with human beings is
not because the animals are behaving
like human beings it's because the human
beings are behaving like animals
and we're we're neglecting and
discarding our higher will and our
reason and our facts and our logic why
do you think that the videos ben kind of
first popularized them but then they
became a whole genre of the internet
so and so destroys such and such with
facts and logic why did that become such
a big phenomenon because we're living in
a culture that increasingly discards
facts and logic and we know that that's
special we know that facts and logic are
special and important and
and something that play a central role
in human life or at least they did until
recently and we miss that that's why
that's why we get all those clicks on
youtube folks
it's also why we're because that the
elephants no matter how advanced they
are
they cannot own you with facts and logic
they will own you with their trunks and
their hoofs and smush you if you cross
them
speaking of animals and the zoo
animals are behaving even in a more
bestial way certainly at the montana zoo
because they're hosting a drag queen
story hour there what is drag queen
story hour
it's when a bunch of perverts discard
facts and reason and logic and they go
and jiggle and twerk and sexualize
little kids and that's what's going on
now at this montana zoo zoo montana in
billings montana has planned the event
for june 22nd coming up get your tickets
now people in the local community don't
want it
people in the local community said hey
man what the heck this is montana this
isn't san francisco this isn't brooklyn
new york get this nonsense out of
montana the zoo's director says no way
the director of zoo montana jeff uwelt
says
we've heard from many of you in regard
to the 406 pride drag queen story hour
being held at the zoo later this month
let me be clear
zoo montana prides itself in being
inclusive of all living things 406 pride
is a respected and valued community
asset one we are proud to support and
host at zoo montana while personal
threats and threats of no longer
supporting the zoo are concerning we
will not let unwarranted fear and hate
deter our decision to move forward with
this harmless and fun reading event so
you get these perverts in some cases
notable cases have been sex offenders to
show up and jiggle half naked for your
little kids that's totally harmless
right it's a fun reading event that's
held throughout the country
unfortunately that's true at the end of
the day
if your personal agenda does not fit
this event we simply ask that you do not
come to the zoo that day it would be a
shame to never allow your children back
to the zoo because of one simple event
happy pride month so there it is
there it is there's the
tyranny of of will you see it again
because there it's the emotional
manipulation there
they say look we know that the community
doesn't want this we know we we might
even be willing to admit in in private
in an honest and candid moment that this
is a little weird and disordered but
look we want to have it
we want to let these weirdos dress up
like chicks and jiggle and twerk for
little kids
and we're going to do that
and your only option is not to come to
the zoo what it sure would be a shame
if your kid didn't get to go to the zoo
anymore what you want to deprive your
kid of the zoo it's the same logic they
use
oh it'd be such a shame not to let your
kids see the animals be such a shame
not to let your kid go to the movies
anymore just because they're they're
turning every movie
into some indoctrination session for
radical leftist ideologies including
sexual ideologies for goodness sakes
there's going to be a lesbian make-out
scene among among lesbian toys and toy
story they have to do it and they say
what you're going to deprive your kid of
toy story
we'll get to that in a second well they
say with school what you're going to
deprive your kid of going to school
yeah look of course we've got to teach
critical race theory in schools
we've got to teach transgenderism in
elementary schools in kindergarten we've
got to
empower the guidance counselors and the
school administrators to trans your kids
and to encourage them to to go on
puberty blockers and cross-sex hormones
in some cases without your knowledge or
consent we have to do all that but what
are you going to do you're going to
deprive your kid of going to school
what a bad parent you are
why is that the choice
look we're just trying to be inclusive
man we're just look we're just trying to
inclusively and diversely and equitably
trans your kids and and convince them to
discard everything you've ever taught
them to believe and convince them to
deny reality and to screw up their body
chemistry for the rest of their lives
that's all we want to do and what and
you're going to deprive them of that no
i'm going to deprive you of your ability
to do that that's what i'm going to do
actually because we have the right and
frankly the obligation in our society to
tell these people no
the zoo
wants to
bring the drag queens to jiggle for your
kids
the community
does not want the zoo to bring the drag
queens to jiggle for the kids
reason and logic and morality and truth
and virtue and all that good stuff is on
the side of the local community
and is against the side of the zoo and
the perverts and the groomers and the
weirdos
so that's one that's one mark for the
local community and furthermore the
local community has political power at
least it did until very recently and i
think it still does
and i think what the local community
needs to do is go in and call this zoo
call up zoo montana i think the members
of zoo montana should call this guy jeff
ewoldt and pull their donations
i think they should call their state
representatives maybe their members of
congress their mayors their every
elected official
who is entrusted by the vote of the
people with the public good with
ensuring
the public good
and go in there and say fire this guy
threaten to take away funding from the
zoo and tell them to cut it out do the
same thing with hollywood do the same
thing with the schools you've seen it
work on the schools in virginia you've
seen it work in florida it can't
ordinary people still have some
political power in this country you've
just got to tell these little tyrants
no
i mentioned buzz lightyear a little bit
earlier
this is the new buzz lightyear movie i
do not intend that well i certainly
don't intend on seeing this movie myself
and i don't intend on taking my little
kid to this movie because the move i
love the toy story movies certainly the
first one was just great but they're all
they're all pretty good they're all kind
of the same movie but they're all good
nice warm wholesome stories characters
nice music
and as always the left has to take a
thing that is good and popular and
beautiful
and then go in and suck out its insides
and drain all the blood out of it and
rot it out from the inside and just use
it as a vessel to push its very radical
political agenda
do you really believe
that the story of light year
of the prequel to toy story
that that the only way to serve that
plot is by inserting a lesbian kiss
scene
no i bet it's completely extraneous to
the plot
in fact the scene was cut previously and
then the disney radical employees
decided to hold throw a big hull of blue
about it and so they put the scene back
in
not to serve the story not for the
benefit of the audience but just because
of these radical leftist activists who
worked for disney so they put the scene
back in
i think now people ought to vote with
their wallets look dw we're out there
making movies we haven't made uh kids
content yet we're investing a ton of
money in it right now by the way we're
going to have kids content very soon
i wouldn't do this
furthermore
i would i would go in
and start exerting a little more
political control over these movies i
know this is anathema to some people who
have imbibed a lot of the platitudes of
the liberal left about how we should
have no limits whatsoever on art that's
totally bunk man all good art every
single piece of good art that has ever
been produced
has limits on it and this is especially
true of movies you're seeing it right
now by the way i think light year has
been banned in 14 countries
because these countries say now we don't
want this woke stuff we don't want this
is just we don't like it we're not going
to do it we're not going to allow it in
tough stuff hollywood and hollywood's
willing to lose money
if they can still push their woke
ideology
but and by the way hollywood is they
fired tim allen who originated the role
he is the voice of buzz lightyear but
they fired him why'd they fire him they
hired chris evans
and you you can't blame this on money
you can't say tim allen was asking for
too much money
i strongly suspect tim allen negotiates
for less money than chris evans does
chris evans right now is a bigger movie
star
but chris evans is a big lib and tim
allen is an outspoken conservative and
so it seems clear to me clear as day
that they fired tim allen from his
beloved and iconic role just for his
politics
and so what are we going to do about
that
we need to put limits on these things
there was a period in the history of
hollywood called the haze code
and today whenever the haze code is
invoked kind of like mccarthyism no one
no one ever really explains what it was
no one ever it's just it's it's got this
insinuation that it was really really
bad and we're not going to tell you what
it was but it was just it was really bad
and censorship and censorship's always
bad and so we got to get rid of that
the haze code was the greatest thing
that ever happened to hollywood and the
greatest movies ever made
almost without there are some exceptions
obviously because it was only a short
period of time but a disproportionate
number of the greatest movies ever made
were made during the period of the haze
code the movies before and after the
haze code were worse
in almost every case before the haze
code which insisted on some standards in
the movies and it lasted from
a 1934 to 1968 so about 34 years decent
period of time
before the haze code movies were weird
and creepy and degenerate and decadent
there's a scene that goes viral
sometimes most people haven't seen the
full movie it's called freaks this is
the kind of stuff you got before the
haze
code maker one of us a loving cop a
loving cop we accept one of us we accept
one of us
they are going to make you one of them
[Laughter]
we accept
not exactly the highest kind of art is
it it's just i mean the movie's called
freaks it was supposed to just be a
freak show and there's no real logic or
reason to it it's just a bunch of people
who look kind of weird just screaming
one of us
and the whole point of that scene
is to just be really weird and to not
really partake of of logic or reason
then you get the haze code
two years later you get the haze code
five years after that you get 1939 the
greatest year for hollywood movies ever
1939 you get the wizard of oz stagecoach
mr smith goes to washington gone with
the wind wuthering heights and that's
not even the whole list
you might say oh those are kind of old
movies compared to
all almost well certainly compared to
any year in hollywood history but just
compare any of those movies to any other
movie there are some of the greatest
movies ever made and they were made with
limits
like a sonnet
like a son like poetry when poetry has
some limits imposed on it
limits like rhyme limits like meter
limits like a certain number of lines
the poems tend to be better
than slam poetry which is the death of
art
that
that is the sort of thing that we might
have to get back to i think
if we want if we want good art
if we want reason if we want logic what
is logic what is reason what is truth
what is goodness if not a limit it's a
limit it says no no we're going to
discard falsehood we're going to discard
bad stuff we're going to discard
ugliness we're going to kind of tamp
that down a little bit it's a limit but
it's a limit that opens you up the
founding fathers didn't talk about how
we need to have licentiousness all the
time and google gobble gobble gobble one
of us
it said the opposite they said we need
ordered liberty
and it's not that there's a conflict
here it's not that they're in opposition
order and liberty they actually work
together
the liberty that is that is exalting
that that lifts your eyes up that is
enabling that is an ordered liberty
this is a very basic idea this is right
at the heart of christianity christ says
the man who sins is a slave to sin some
people think that sinning is a high form
of liberty you know you get to shoot up
the heroin or whatever or have a you
know a throuple monkey pox party or some
google gobble google gobble that's not
that's anyone who's ever been in the
throes of any semblance of an addiction
knows it's actually slavery
and it enslaves us to a culture it's
decadent and weird that doesn't even
make sense you can't govern yourself if
you're in a culture where you can't
speak and understand one another where
we're all just sitting around a table
saying google gobble google apple google
google gobble it's even hard to say it
it's even hard to get those very words
out
if we want a society
that is good and ordinary and lets us
actually be free we need those limits
and the libs know it too by the way i'll
just tease this story but we'll have to
get to it later this week
the left backed in large part by george
soros is right now attempting to buy up
all sorts of spanish-speaking radio
stations to censor them to censor the
conservatives to try to create the
limits that they want the really bad
limits for their really bad society we
need to think more deeply about this too
we need to push for some action we need
to stop global gobbling i'm michael
knowles this is the michael knowles show
see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
on the matte wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show